THE HOP AND A ZONE,
ARVIDSSON LEFT WING DRIVES THEA.
STRETCH OUT, PAD, MAKE THE STOP.
TRANSITION.CE-OFF
LOOK AT THIS.
WIDE OPEN DOWN THE MIDDLE.
KINGS ARE A LITTLE BIT SLOW BUT
THE LINE RUSHES ON THE WING WITH
RASMUS KUPARI AND DUSTIN BROWN
ON IN, KAAPO KAKKO CAREER.
PETERSON, OVER.
TWO
BEST ON THE PENALTY KILL.
THE KIN THE
TRIGGER GLOVE BY GEORGIEV.
>> Jim: FUSE TO AND
IT'S KNOCKED DOWN BY GEORGIEV,
OR ONE OF HIS
NINTH IN THE LEAGUE IN POWER  H
EVERY SHIFT, CHANCE TO GET TO
TOP SPEED AND HE WAS UNABLE TO
SLOW DO THAT IS CAL  SHOT AWAY
FROM THEM IN THE FIRST PERIOD SO
THE KINGS GOING NINE PLUS
MINUTES WITHOUT ALLOWINGMIDDLE.
WATCH THIS, LEAN,  THE KINGS BRE
HERE.
AGAIN WITH A GOAL WITHSTRUM,
LIFTED OUT BY THE
AND MORE OUT OF TREVOR.
AND WATCH HERE, THE BACKHAND
PASS,E A CHANGE.
THAT LINE
LIZOTTE INSIDE POSITION AGAINST
TINORDI, INSIDE  THE WALL OF KI
JUST SWOONED. FOR A
FACE-OFF.
>> Jim: MOST POWER PLAYS AREKAL
GETTING DIFFERENT PLAYERS DOING
THAT.
SO NOW IT'S UP CHANCE
KICKED AWAY BYM.
MIKEY ANDERSON COMES OVER RIGHT
AT THE RIGHT TIME WITH THE STICK
LEADING THE PLAY TO OPEN, SHOT .
>> Jim: MAYBE MORE THAN ANYTHING
FOR THE RANGERS, IT'S A
DOUGHTY FOR KOPITAR. WHEN IT BR
DOWN, KINGS GET IN THE WAY, FRO
GOT A PIECE, DOUGHTY